Spooky.
Moe Moe Boo!
Gochitin Tama!
Hello everybody!
Hi!
Hi, hi!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome in, welcome in!
Moe Moe Boo.
That's what I said.
Don't wear it out.
No dolphin works.
Thank you for the hot dog.
Good, good, good, good, good, good.
Love the new Ori song.
Thank you!
What's Minto Grilling?
Can I get a happy birthday?
Zanko, Fanko, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Amazing concert.
I loved watching.
Everyone did so good.
Thank you, Fallon.
Thank you.
Bro, thanks for the hot dog.
ViviCourt, thank you so much for the pie.
Good night.
Hello, everybody.
How are you guys doing today?
Happy Friday.
Wow.
Are you a creature in the kitchen?
We're all creatures in the kitchen today.
Can we add a disclaimer for my cats that we are not making
them dinner?
It is not time for this.
Are they like trained when Minto stream comes on that it's
eating time?
Stand mixer We're making waffles It's not my birthday today.
Happy not birthday Oh, you're just you're just living today.
You're just existing Couple wow.
Thank you so much for the third Super chat ever
It's cool you're going to be a part of the Ayami Family 3D
Live.
Can't wait to see you perform with your mama and your
sisters.
Thank you.
Doki, thanks for the gift.
Thank you so much.
Forever third.
Hey, at least you're placing, right?
Yeah, so much is happening, right?
Ayami Family Cafe, Colabo Cafe, So, um, I'll be on my mama's
channel for White Day.
White Day, I'll be there.
Um, can't always catch your streams due to time zones, but
it's always a tree, but I can.
Dayaboro, thank you!
Thank you for your own food.
Thank you for the gift.
Crayon Marion.
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you so much.
I hope you guys are doing...
You guys have any plans for the weekend?
Yeah, and then me later today!
raiding into Nimi's concert tonight.
So I am a guest in it.
So I'm very, very excited.
I mean, don't go to Japan in a few weeks.
I was wondering if I could get some English-friendly main
Cafe Rex.
A lot of them are pretty English-friendly.
And Akihabara especially.
I would say most have...
Watch Nimi then.
Sushi with the boys.
Let's go.
I would say...
like made dreaming at home um uh are there english
unfriendly well it's it's not that they're unfriendly um
there are some maid cafes that they do have english menus
but some not entirely of their menus are in english and then
some some maid cafes have like better english speakers than
others that's why i bring up like at home or Made Dreamin.
They're very, very used to foreigners.
So, if you're like, I know Zero Nihongo, I would say made
Dreamin or at home.
I still vividly recall you singing Dreamin Passport at
Phantom.
Arigato, Arigato, too.
Yeah, I did sing Dreamin Passport.
Mr. Mayhem, thank you!
But later jazz showed on.
Thank you for such a beautiful evening.
Not gonna lie, I got a little misty at times.
Getting to see you up on stage and living your dream.
Hope to see you there a lot more in the future.
Thank you.
Does Ike and Bukuro have any maid cafes?
They do.
Yeah, they do.
I'll be honest though.
I don't think I've been to any in Ike and Bukuro.
Now that I think about it, I convinced another Aibu to go to
deer stage.
I-I-I-I-Iry!
I love Iry!
She's so cute!
I love Iry.
Oh my gosh.
Have fun!
I want to go to deer stage.
Ikebukuro has swallow tail.
I'm pretty sure that's an Ikebukuro.
The Butler Cafe.
Isekai-made cafe was fun when I went last fall.
I love the Isekai-made cafe.
Yeah, there's so many fun-made cafes.
I love all the different themed ones, too.
They're so fun.
Yes, yes.
Creature kitchen.
The creatures are in my kitchen.
I am the creature in the kitchen.
We're creature-ing it up in the kitchen.
Creature feature in the kitchen.
Kitchen creature.
Who is the kitchen and who is the creature?
I'm- wait.
Wait.
Who is the creature in the kitchen?
Featuring the creature.
And the Pinar Snipper guy.
I'm excited to play this!
Oh my gosh.
So I found this game through another streamer that I
watched.
and I'm gonna be honest right now he was playing a game I
was watching right before stream and I was like I don't want
to stop watching I think I'm addicted to watching this guy
play this game and so I might play that game too because it
looks so fun thank you so much for bamboo show you know the
feeling sometimes I'll like watch a stream stream or play a
game and I'll be like oh my gosh this looks so fun I have to
stop watching so that I can play it myself you know being
Nihongo Jozu by a maid in a cafe is my goal oh you could you
got this you got this I believe in yeah but anyway it says
resume game but I didn't start one so let's do a new game
I'm excited oh is that you a little F or flashlight.
Oh.
Wow.
What a beautiful heart.
Ooh.
It's not you.
Follow the Aibu.
Can I run?
Oh.
Is this my home or?
It's your home?
What's that?
Minto fell down a well!
Oh.
Possession.
I got a key.
To...
Oh, this door?
Maybe?
Cute.
Yeah, it's my home now.
That looks intimidating.
Anyway.
So this is like, I guess not quite a horror game, but it's a
little...
Oh, what's this?
I got...
scary meatballs!
But it's a bit of a...
Oh, read me, please.
Okay.
It's a bit of a kind of a creepy, cozy...
See it to crouch.
We got Eggie Sando.
Who the heck is the new hat, man?
Oh, I can turn off my flashlight.
man he looks like little may a little bit shut the door oh
hey we'll just keep this you know candle lots of that looks
like a spooky guy he totally does do you see it it looks
like little may I love I love Little Mae.
She's my favorite in...
in... in...
um...
Flower.
So we're gonna be cooking stuff, guys.
I got PB&J.
Um, she's my favorite in Moomin.
We got pasta.
We got salt.
Wait, is it pre-cooked pasta?
Or post-cooked?
Is it cooked pasta?
We got a spray bottle.
We got a maple syrup.
Sponge, soap, all these lovely ingredients that we can make
a pizza pie.
Oh, that one's locked.
Peanut butter.
Wait.
Oh, bread.
All right, let's read this.
Read me, please.
Hello, my dear.
Thank you for looking after my home on such short notice.
My departure must be very concerning.
Food.
Oh, food.
No.
want to drink oh wow
you're so brave for admitting that
uh keep them fed and you should have nothing to worry about
if you need some ideas for meals keep an eye out there
should be recipe cards yeah we already found some scattered
about take care and remember to make good memories xx
magnets nude done wait done D O N E done or did you just say
node I heard a door open did you just say node did a door
open here No.
I don't think we can go on these.
The moon room.
The tear room.
The heart room.
I'm gonna, maybe we will keep this light on.
After all.
What recipes do we have?
Toast!
Pancake!
Eggie sandal.
Maybe we enjoy sandal.
Spaghetti and meatballs.
French fries.
Mistake!
Okay.
Oh, bad combo.
Mistake.
That was number 43 though.
Okay, we got a lot.
Let's see.
Cooking basics.
The oven.
In out of the oven.
Of the oven.
In out in...
If oven... Wait, if you...
If...
every meal is play no made oh my gosh i can't read today
every meal is made by placing ingredients in the oven close
the door to inform the unit your offerings are ready be
patient and linger not long near the void of creation safe
cutting if you need to slice an ingredient a knife is your
best bet for the safety of your countertop always use a
cutting board If rage overtakes you, put the knife down.
Solid advice.
Offerings, yeah, to me.
Blend ingredients once placed in a bowl.
Make sure you mix in a consistent direction.
Should you need to empty the bowl, use the spring-loaded
plate beneath to eject its contents.
Fast-frying.
Fry up your ingredients to bring out their savory flavors.
in the pan flip and cook to the other side in kitchen
emergencies the pan can be used for self-defense i hope i'm
not fighting anything anything on the radio
i offer myself as tribute the hunger games the creature
games i don't know
why did i make my flashlight zip
eyes ambient mixes summer storm may be brewing out there but
we'll be here to ride out the whole night don't touch that
dial don't touch that dial says the guy in bt and then we
have this this thing over here what is this our family
example wants nothing this is an example okay take a photo
of a creature to learn what meals they want Ah, feed each
creature a handful of different meals to become friends.
When you earn three hearts, you'll be gifted a key.
She loves the music of the winds.
Always chittering beneath the porch.
Seems to think he owns the place.
I don't know how people consider these little guys' pests.
They always clean the floor for me.
Oh my gosh, it's like having a dog.
He'll never turn down a dimly lit picnic by the fog.
Sorry, river.
If you're quick enough, you might catch a glimpse of this
little demon.
Wait, there's a demon in our pantry?
Sure likes making messes in the pantry.
Oh, maybe these are in the bedrooms.
Oh, this thing has been here for a long time.
Is it still a dog house when there's not a dog around?
Okay, let's start at the very beginning with this guy.
Do you think I'm going to get copyright for this?
Thank you.
There's a demon.
Wait, oh, there's a camera.
Nice.
Right click to take a photo.
Oh, he's so cute.
The pseudo-nervina.
Let's go.
Did she just say nerd?
And so now I look in here.
Once any two meals.
How do I put this down?
Oh, my bad.
Put it on the table.
Oh, okay, easy.
Ew, what is this?
Slop?
Oh no, it's cooking slopkin.
Alright, let's see what recipe.
Let's toast.
Bread slice.
I had bread...
In here.
So we gotta slice some bread.
Oh, golly.
I'm feeling it, guys.
The rage.
I'm feeling it overcome me.
Bread slice.
So...
I guess I just toasted in the oven?
Is that what it means?
Oh, heavens.
This is easy to burn.
Luckily, my oven knows how to create just about anything.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh,
and it said stand away.
Definitely not cooking, ma'am.
Oh!
Wow!
My one slice became two!
And with the butter!
How handy!
Toast for you!
Oh!
How'd the butter get on?
Don't question my magic.
So cute!
Cook a reunion dinner for us?
Toast.
Buttered toast.
Look at the moon.
Oh.
Oh wow, there's so much stuff out here.
Okay.
What the?
I need to get my camera.
Trash cat!
Oh, that's a terrible thing.
photo though.
We gotta get a better one of that guy.
Wait, I can't toss it.
Okay, hold on.
Little guy!
Where'd he go?
Trash cat!
You were in the bushes.
Woo!
Hello!
Oh, that's a mushroom.
Oh, oops.
Oh, mushroom discovered.
All right, hold on.
I'm looking for my cat.
Come back, stuffy!
Yeah.
The music...
Wait, that's a cute one.
It's kind of creepy.
TJ, thank you so much for the captain!
We'll keep that one.
Where does he keep going?
Is there a hole in here?
I can't walk into the bush.
Alright.
Um, I need two meals.
That's this guy, the one that is chittering under the porch.
He wants two sandwiches.
Alright.
Well, I...
Okay, so we made the toast.
What else can we make?
Sandwiches.
We can make pancakes with dough.
Okay, I saw the maple syrup.
Do I put it in the...
We're just gonna put everything in the oven.
Dough.
Mix flour and water.
I remember the flour was...
Yeah, here.
And then this is our mixing bowl, right?
Okay.
Reese, thank you!
Water?
Did we see water?
Spray bottle?
Salt.
Pasta.
This was peanut butter.
Maybe in our pantry?
I'm afraid of the demon.
Oh!
Oh, the salt.
Sink!
But what would I collect it in?
My hands?
How would I collect this?
Oh, hold left click to activate.
Yes, yes.
Namie, thank you so much for the...
Great!
I'm making pancakes in my oven.
I think this is how it works.
Maple syrup and dough.
Welcome in!
Welcome!
Oh, it says done.
Please don't be a mistake.
That looks good!
I can't steal two thank you!
Where's the butter coming from?
I'm nervous.
Yummy.
I know, I wish it were like this too.
Those look good.
Become friends with a creature.
Oh, he loves me.
Can I pet you?
No.
I got a fish key.
Which opens.
The refruit- I should close the pantry, huh?
Nah, well, thank you so much for the 10 get there!
Oh, this is where the butter is coming from!
And so much lettuce!
Who's missing?
One strawberry!
Is there like a...
Let's just close this.
It says we have to be fast, right?
To get the demon?
Has a knack for finding things.
Seems to like music.
Might be a bit of a thief.
Let us cook.
Alright, we got it.
We got trash cat here.
Who wants two sandwiches?
I think we had an eggy sandal.
Yeah.
And PB&J?
It's the thumbnail!
Let's do that one.
Bread slice two.
Peanut butter and jam.
We got to mix.
Oh, this is perfect.
Okay.
Two bread slices.
Peanut butter.
Do I lose these once I use them?
They don't respawn, it seems.
Strawberry.
Did we see sugar?
Broth?
Tomato.
Sugar!
Okay.
Mix.
Plus.
Strawberry.
Wow.
We're making the jam for this guy.
What is it?
Oh, egg.
Why is it different?
Oh!
Oh, it changes.
Again.
It looks like my mozzarella and tomato right now.
Sugar bottom, right?
Here, here, here, here.
We packaged it all up.
This is a reminder you're amazing.
Very entertaining.
I am?
Thank you, Wiggle.
Thank you.
I guess that is really a jam, right?
It's just sugar.
And the...
The...
What's it called?
Um...
The fruit?
Sugar and berry?
Alright, PB&J Sandy.
Coming up!
Little God!
The...
The storm is so loud for how clear the night is.
Little guy!
Where?
Uh oh!
Little guy!
Yeah, you're under the porch!
What's going on here?
Coffee!
We're gonna get a cat and a bat and Minecraft Steve!
There he is!
You want this PPHI?
What
were you...
Oh, you were trying the mushroom.
Oh, oh, we have a little grave here.
Interesting.
Fascinating.
I scared him away.
What?
Where is he?
I heard him.
I heard him chittering.
Hey!
Maybe I have to...
There's no plate for him, so maybe I like throw it at him.
Is there stuff over here?
I'm exploring a little bit.
Oh!
I'm exploring now.
Oh, okay.
That's how we throw it.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, it's...
Ah!
I got a carrot.
And...
Omelette.
With a carrot?
I guess you could.
I wish my oven had the vacuum of deep space.
Yeah, but your pantry would have a demon in it, so...
You pick your battles, I suppose.
Hello!
Little critter, creature.
Oh!
He's a fan!
The moon shower is beautiful tonight.
Isn't it?
Snuffy!
Come here!
Come here, Snuffy!
Come here.
Let me crawl into your hole.
I feed you and this is how you repay me.
Z to magnify.
Whoa.
Our clock.
It's...
I'm guessing that's 3.30 a...
Wait!
I think this is a real time.
It's 3.30 p.m.
for me.
my
god cheese and crackers
cheese and crackers I like the music a lot okay um we had an
eggy sandal right spaghetti and meatballs french fries
cheese and crackers
eggy sand here bread slice to fry fried egg.
Oh, we haven't been able to fry anything yet.
Good thing I've...
Oh, wow, look, it really is...
Can I put myself on?
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh, well, we're making toast.
Have a good stream!
Thank you!
Choo!
Hello, Mito and I booze IQ!
Coming to you from Streamlabs because YouTube doesn't want
me to donate for some reason today.
Oh, no!
That's okay.
Save your mind.
Come on, save your money!
Sorry, I'm being late.
No, you're not late!
Long day at the paint spilling factory.
I hope you are doing all today and I hope the creatures are
chilled.
We're having dust!
Can I eat it?
Alright.
Dang, I wasted a bread slice.
Well, it was one of the ends.
It was one of the ends.
So hopefully, you know, the pieces that nobody likes.
Alright, so we're frying an egg now.
Oh.
Whoa.
Ooh.
Oh yeah.
Wait.
Uh, flip.
I'm assuming this is the other side.
They look the same.
Oh, this is, oh my gosh, this is the most well buttered,
oiled pan ever.
Maybe not.
Maybe I need to flip it.
Flip.
They all look the same.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, I left my fridge open.
I'm the worst.
Arctic eggs.
I've wanted to try playing that game before.
Eggie...
With the tomato!
Hot dog.
Sandwich.
Little friend.
I know you're out and about.
There you go.
He loves it.
I'm lost in that oven.
Wait, the way he runs is so cute.
Oh, thank you.
Are we friends now?
Hands in the air.
We got a key, a square key.
Wait, oh here!
Cheese!
Cheese to meet you.
Oh, cheese?
And a pizza!
A new friend, a new friend!
Con!
Ooh, mid-action shot.
A plus.
Wait, are you eating the...
Guys, there's somebody outside.
He ate the slop.
Oh!
He's in the chair now.
Are we friends now?
Oh, that was so sweet!
Wait, I missed this under here.
What is this?
Okay.
There's much to this game now, isn't there?
We got a little mouse.
Want three snacks with cheese.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Them.
How mysterious.
Cheese and crackers we have.
Does omelette have cheese?
Technically.
Is omelette a snack?
Does spaghetti and meatballs have cheese?
No.
It's not good spaghetti and meatballs.
Cheese and crackers.
We got two cheese.
Pizza.
Does pizza count as a snack?
This one's quite intensive.
We gotta mix a bunch of stuff.
Let's start with our omelet.
We have to slice a bunch of stuff.
Oh, wow.
We're slicing cheese.
Oh.
Slice.
Feeling a rage.
Overcoming me.
We're slicing a mushroom and a tomato.
That's a strawberry.
Tomatoes were in here.
Blade mode.
Mushroom.
Wait, what am I making?
Oh, an omelet.
Ew, with a mushroom?
Ew.
And watch this, watch this.
Oh, yeah!
I might be the most skilled at it all.
Wait, why are we frying the egg to make the omelet?
I think I gotta go get a mushroom.
We'll let him be.
Here's one.
Who is here, Grandma?
Just one slice.
Whoa!
Boy, this thing is huge!
I can't even see the eggy anymore!
It's overcome with mushroom!
Yeah, we don't question the oven.
The oven...
That looks incredible!
What the heck?
There you go.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It sounded almost like he was going to go
Today's my birthday!
Happy birthday!
Alright, what else?
That was an omelet.
How many did he want?
Three?
I think?
Three snacks with cheese.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, oh, yeah, okay.
May your scars stay blue.
Pizza.
Flower and water.
How am I supposed to...
You guys say I should get it from the sink, but I don't know
how.
Flower?
I think I get it from in here.
Okay.
Oh, oh, thank goodness.
I'm too scared of the demon.
I'm too scared of the demon, I think.
Nice.
But you're a ghost.
But I'm not a demon.
All right, tomato and salt.
When I run out, will I be able to get more?
Sure he's chill.
Alright, we'll brave it.
We'll brave it right after this.
We'll be brave.
And we'll go into the pantry.
It looks humongous.
We jarred it even?
And a cheese slice.
Good thing I have all my food right here.
Cross-contamination be damned.
Don't be afraid.
We don't bite much.
I don't know.
After the omelette, I really expected like Michelin Star.
That one kind of looked a little.
It's pizza.
It's the best pizza in all of London.
You like that?
Oh yeah.
Get in your hall.
Alright, so we did...
We did the omelette.
What do I need for the cheese and crackers?
I don't think we have that.
And three cheese slice.
We don't...
Wait, we don't have crackers.
One.
Oh no!
Wasting a whole wedge for this.
Can I just cut off one?
No.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll go into the pantry and we will explore.
Alright.
I keep forgetting to show it.
Crackers!
Any crackers in here?
Wait, it says...
What does it say for the demon?
We could bring my...
If you're quick enough, you might catch a glimpse of this
little demon.
Sure likes making messes.
Okay, let's bring our camera.
See if we can get them.
Any crackers?
Yeah!
Oh no!
Oh no.
Oh, there's mushroom.
Okay, the things are in here.
This is...
Oh my gosh.
Grandma is rich.
I have my button.
I have my finger on the...
The button.
What's happening?
Do you guys see any crackers?
I'm gonna get...
Oh, I'm scared!
Oh,
wait, is this the demon?
Yay!
I didn't see any crackers.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Oh.
Okay.
Awesome.
Gulba wants three tastes of Italy.
Okay, but I need crackers though.
Where can I get crackers from?
I looked in all of these, right?
No crackers maybe it maybe do I have another cheese recipe
Okay, hold on let's look around then I Was like so could I
was so distracted by this guy.
I didn't see the symbols.
Okay
Dog man dog one man four cross seven Nine nine dog one can
I take this no okay I can't go in any of these does any of
these is that a dog in popcorn it looks like his head is
poking out oh oh nine nine nine Dog one Cross seven Seven
Human four Crackers Oh And we got Alfredo Oh Bye
Yes Oh Whoa I like how the cheese almost looks like almost
looks like butter.
Dang, she cooking.
We're cooking, baby.
Give me my key, little friend.
Yay!
Oh, a heart key.
Wait, we get to go into the bedroom.
Mouse facts.
Mouse love grains, seeds, nuts, bacon, chocolate, peanut
butter, and ghosts.
Especially floofy-eared ghosts who work as maids.
I didn't shut that So whoever is knocking Shut the door so
that they could knock at the door
Is that me?
Is that a little ghost at the door?
Why won't you come on?
Oh, okay, you're welcoming
She's all legs!
Why, hello.
Uh, uh, uh.
Let me get you.
I like him kicking his feet.
This is literally me, baby.
Pants!
He's pants!
You're just pants.
Who are you?
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
One specific dish.
Took me a while to figure out what he wants.
so I keep his favorite snack stashed away from the other
critters.
Okay.
Is he just gonna hang around?
Stashed?
Wait, was there anything in here?
Oh, yeah.
Maybe it's something we haven't unlocked yet?
There's still, like, this?
Oh, that looks like a coffee, though, or something.
Or in here?
This one has nothing written, so let's...
The crackers were stashed.
Yes, they were.
Uh, I don't even see any.
Oh, here they are.
Let's try.
Do you like this?
No.
Okay.
Anyway, what's in here?
Ooh, enter the bedroom.
Kenopsia.
We got owls.
Owl puzzle.
We got chocolate bar and chocolate chip cookies.
Music's getting a little creepy.
We got this side up.
Okay.
Very interesting.
We got chipies.
We got another recipe for chocolate ice cream.
We got a book.
Is that right?
Is that...
Huh.
A coffee maker!
Weather...
Oh!
Here we go.
Showers expected throughout the day for Sunday.
Showers.
Monday.
Clouds rolling in all day with a little sun.
Okay, clouds.
Tuesday.
Light showers.
Oh, no.
Rain showers.
okay more showers on wednesday
thunderstorms thursday thunderstorm thursday but then friday
it is cloudy oh that was easy blueberries and we got
blueberry pie I like how I just throw everything on the
ground.
Did I kill these ones?
Wait, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
What's this?
Read me.
Bloobs.
We got the bloobs.
Thanks, Weatherminto.
Of course, that will be the forecast for your forecasting
area.
Boo berries.
Happy wanderings, my dear.
I feel my or rather our friends in the shadows holding
trepidation in their hearts.
farewells are a challenge I am quite loath to be the proctor
of looking at dancing pale eyes a question lingers how did I
arrive many dozens of crescents have soared above to the
point those memories are blurred a question that needs
answering sooner than later for this family what are you
talking about grandma got strawberry ice cream oh
There's an alien in this box!
Oh, I don't have a camera.
Wait, how did that happen?
Oh, pants is gone!
It took too long!
Oh!
Oh, Jake!
We all know Jake!
I think this is a better one.
There we go.
Jake, silly Jake.
See this one?
Oh, he wants three varieties of dessert.
Oh, best not to move the boxes.
I think it's stressed when things change around it.
Okay, let's see.
I'm getting a little ahead of myself, I feel.
They're huge!
I hope there's only two of them.
Not mice.
Guess I should clean up after myself.
Oh yeah, he's going to eat the food on the ground.
Two sandwiches.
Lives under the house.
Gotta remember to take the trash out.
Running on two legs?
Okay.
But we have Gooberry right now, so we can do the three
tastes of Italy, I think.
What's that?
Like, spaghetti, pizza, Alfredo?
Probably.
Probably, right?
Spaghetti, Alfredo, pizza?
Let's do Alfredo first.
Cheese.
And milk.
And pasta.
Oh.
Milk?
Oh, wait.
I have to mix the milk and the cheese, right?
Yeah.
Cheese wedge, please.
Not lettuce.
Cheese.
No!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
What does the red X on the food mean?
What red X?
Cheese.
Cheese sauce.
This bite of Italy is a tad too rich for me.
Uh-oh.
When you look at the recipe box.
Oh, look.
It says it does not stand close.
Oh, like this?
Oh, this means that we've made it before.
Oh, yum.
Spaghetti Alfredo pizza sounds kind of like an interesting
pizza.
Oh, I was just talking to a friend earlier about...
My crackers!
I was just talking to my friend about a mac and cheese
pizza.
Oh, he's eating it!
Okay, that's one.
Hey, get in your hole!
Get in your hole!
Don't eat the chocolate!
Or anything else.
We got one.
Let's make a pizza.
I'm feeling so Italian.
Oh no, we'll make spaghetti.
Pasta.
Does pasta stay in the fridge?
Because it's like...
Already cooked?
I guess not.
It was in the...
The cabinet, right?
Oh.
pasta pasta plus tomato sauce and ground beef mix raw steak
and salt okay we got a raw steak here um where was the salt
did i pick that up already before oh yeah we have because we
had to make a we had to make some other stuff like the
tomato sauce i remember I don't have anything of substance
to say, but I received my first credit card today.
Can't pay for supertats on that one, but it's crazy.
Maple pancake, thank you!
Now you're gonna use that responsibly, right?
You're gonna use that responsibly, right?
Oh, beef.
And tomato.
I think we need more salt.
I'm working on it.
If I miss a puzzle, feel free to be like, hey, by the, like,
if I'm like, I don't know what to do, you could be like, by
the way, you forgot this puzzle.
Supporting Minto is responsible.
No.
Skiety time.
Minto's homemade spaghetti in the oven of space and time and
time.
I think you left something in the bucket under the sink.
Oh, that looks good.
Hey!
Do you like to cook?
I shouldn't cook.
That'd be bad, Drew.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Get that!
The credit card company told me that the super chats are
free.
Just...
They're trying...
They're doing...
They're bamboozling you!
Oh, you're right.
Oh, my gosh.
There's a meatball sub in there.
Is that Italian?
It's fine.
We were making a pizza anyway.
It's a pizza, pizza, pizza.
Cheese slice, tomato sauce, dough.
Good thing we have a cheese slice right here.
And we know how to make dough.
Flour.
Water.
I'm house sitting, but I don't think I'm very good at it.
I just leave all of my doors open.
Being so responsible.
Thank you.
Would love a magic oven.
I think everybody would love a magic oven like that, no?
Just throw a bunch of stuff in there.
But what if you keep making mistakes?
It seems very specific, no?
It seems like you need to get everything the proper...
the proper amount of everything
I want to see what a mistake is though we'll just throw some
stuff in maybe
do they just have things no okay did I grab everything out
of everything sugar I'll throw that down there broth okay
broth discovered alright throw that there tomato tomato I
think so now.
Pizza, pizza, pizza, from Italia.
With great streams come great responsibility.
Or am I thinking of something else?
Jack, thank you!
Thank you so much for one year.
Oh.
We got ourselves a key, baby.
Hi, Minto.
Today is not my birthday, so you are absolutely not allowed
to wish me a happy weather thank you you guys tricked me
bill for my letters thank you so much for the time gifted
thank you oh what is this open the shed oh the infinite food
closet is terrifying my grandmother had one in her secret
basement made bomb shelter back in world war ii was 50 feet
long straight had a single way so exactly that one oh enter
the shed
are we at oh are we in space philly cheese steak in the shed
tortilla in the shed beef stew in the shed dig into fertile
Put seeds in hole.
Cover seeds with dirt.
Water grants life.
Oh, it's probably that...
It's probably the...
What's it called, right?
That grave that we saw.
Cue banjo music.
Bang, bang, bang.
Come here.
Thank you!
A full invention.
What is this?
Oh, is it one of these?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh.
Oh!
I was so close.
Nachos!
Oh, we got the seeds!
Okay.
What did it say?
Rose seeds.
Okay.
But it, um...
So, shovel.
Let's go dig that hole.
Right?
He loves me!
He's not running away!
I'm just kidding, he's running away.
I wonder if there's different types of mushroom.
Like that one looks mysterious.
Oh wait, where'd my shovel go?
Glad I wasn't the only one thinking of Outer Wild's music.
What seeds?
I know the order.
There are five mushrooms.
There are?
Well, we got the big guy.
That was a big mushroom.
This looks like the same big mushroom.
I wonder if we use the dog toy on the...
Oh wait, there's another one.
Mushroom discovered.
Oh, I think they are different.
So yeah, this was a different kind of mushroom.
Carrot on the ground.
I'm like making such a mess.
I wonder if we use the dog toy on the dog.
House.
Come here, boy!
The skinniest dog ever!
Wait.
I can't see you!
He's all... He looks all... He looks like a twig!
Stick bugged!
Stick dogged!
Oh my god!
It's worse than I thought.
Let me do it for you!
Oh, and he's really cute!
I wish I could pet him.
Let me do it for you.
Yeah, he's hungry for sure.
We'll feed that guy.
Um, what was I working on?
Okay, so we just got a goober.
Little silly goober.
Oh, I gotta take a picture of him.
What do you want?
stretch.
Gray!
Aww.
Oh, I was planting the rose.
You're so right.
Whoa.
He's my friend.
It's all spooky.
I wonder if who's decorating these?
Us or them?
Jake.
Jake wants three varieties of dessert.
He wants three meals with beef.
This thing has been here a long time.
And then we still gotta do the picnic.
Haven't gotten that one yet.
I know.
I hope they update the game where you can pet the animals
once they're your friends, you know.
Oh, there it is.
We planted this.
Did I plant it?
I don't think I did.
Yes, I did.
Oh, I just threw the whole packet in.
Okay, good.
And then we water it.
Water, water, water.
Oh, I think I need to put water on it.
That would make sense.
Come on, you got this?
Oh!
What you grilled cheese!
Oh my god!
Oh, there's water in it.
Okay, good, good.
Oh!
Oh, water is last.
Wait, my shovel, though.
Wait, hold on.
Run.
Oh, whoa.
Oh!
Meatloaf!
That probably requires a beef, you know?
This game is so cozy.
Oh, oops.
I forgot where I was going.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
beauty and the beast.
Oh, the dog is kind of scary when he walks around.
You're a good boy.
Are you shaking?
Oh, he's hungry.
Wait, are you afraid of this?
You don't...
Lana, thank you so much for the read the book.
Thank you.
Hello, hello.
Cool, are we romancing?
We're romancing.
Jake.
Come on, Jake.
You want three desserts.
Oh my god!
He had a burger under his box!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so we do have this owl puzzle.
I don't know quite yet.
What is...
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, I think it's another one of these.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Oh, it literally has numbers with the leaves.
I just saw.
I play play.
Oh, I didn't discover what the, I didn't see what the recipe
was.
I was brute forcing it, but there's literally leaves with
numbers on them.
Oopsie.
I love brute forcing stuff, though.
I just noticed that this is like a butterfly on some
bananas.
I'm not quite sure the meaning of it all.
Grandma has some...
Grandma's erred.
Oh, there's water in here.
She has some interesting taste, huh?
Wait, what if grandma really is dead?
What if the ghost that we saw at the beginning was grandma
leading us to the house so that we could feed her friends?
Because they will be hungry without her, and she actually
did die.
isn't a flower everybody our final meal we will be eating
grandma crayon me thank you so much for the vibe get this
would have grandma's pants what a sentence grandma she's
pants she's pants oh my gosh this clock really is accurate
that's scary immersive okay let's work on
Before we get this guy, let's do Jake.
Actually, actually, I realize this guy might give us a key
to unlock another ingredient, you know, so rather than a
door.
So we'll turn, never turn down a dimly lit picnic.
Where?
I didn't see a picnic.
Is it out here?
Oh!
Oops.
Oh, here it is.
Here it is.
Mason jar.
And a recipe.
Mushroom stir-fry.
Right-click to gather.
Oh!
How sweet!
Wait.
I've lost.
Oh, here it is.
Uh-oh.
Hopper!
Mix the ashes with the flower and apple to make grandma's
apple pie.
You would not believe your eyes.
Oh, I don't think this guy...
This guy would not believe his eyes.
Oh, there's something else over here.
Fish.
We don't have fish yet.
It's so beautiful.
Is there anything else?
What else is out here?
We came from this way, no?
But it seems a lot longer than when we first started.
Oh, I don't think I can go any further.
Oh, another type of mushroom.
Yes.
Very good.
I think I've discovered every mushroom type.
Perhaps.
That frog he ate grandma's apple pie.
Good morning, Mitao.
Good morning.
Alright, what's the frog want?
Hopper wants two dishes from the yard.
What?
Mushroom dishes?
That's what I was thinking.
perhaps we do have a mushroom stir-fry pasta butter
butter pasta our pantry is really filling out I was thinking
either from ingredients in the yard or recipes we found in
the yard but I can't remember what maybe I feel like we
found the Mushroom stir-fry in the yard, right?
Mushroom slice times two.
Bread, bread.
Mushroom slice one.
Yes, very good.
Sorry, it's a little stale.
Yeah, it could be either one.
We'll figure it out.
Hopefully ingredients.
I hope so, too.
Why is my flashlight going out?
Oh, it looks terrible.
That's not my best work, everybody.
I apologize.
It's not my best work at all.
Hello?
Oh, my God.
Oh, he loved it!
Okay, and he only wants two things, so we'll do another
mushroom dish.
A good chef blaves their oven.
Run.
Alright.
Mushroom stir fry.
Do we have anything else with mushroom?
Nachos.
When did I get that?
Frogs only want two things.
They're disgusting.
Oh, the shed.
Oh, okay.
There was something else that I made with a mushroom slice?
But I don't remember what it was.
Oh, it's the omelet.
I don't know.
Do you guys think it's...
What's something that I found in the yard?
Another recipe.
I guess nachos we found technically in the shed, right?
Did you check the rain gutter near the rose?
No.
Oh, the carrot!
Oh!
Mushroom soup!
Oh, that hits both things.
From the yard and also...
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Whoever said that.
Yippee!
Broth, mushroom slice to potato slice.
Wait, do I have potatoes?
I must, right?
Because I must, because we have a French fry recipe.
Mushroom slice.
Potatoes?
Any taters?
What is that?
That looks like a mushroom.
Oh, here we go, potato.
Who let the minky in the kitchen?
I'm so sorry I just woke up.
No, you're all good.
It's 4 a.m.
here.
Today's my birthday.
Ah, happy birthday.
This slice is for you.
I need one more mushroom.
One more mushroom.
I'm going to chop.
I'm feeling the rage.
Oh.
What was this again?
Oh, toast.
I had to blow my nose!
Hold on.
Make you rage.
Oh, why does all the mushroom stuff look terrible?
I bag it up.
Full of love.
Full of love for you, little frog.
Oh my gosh.
I want to see him run on his legs again.
Wish I could cook gourmet meals by throwing random things in
a... in an oven.
Kee!
Thank you!
Bye bye, Hopper!
Bye bye!
I know, this game... Oh, we get the freezer!
This game is like a simulation almost, but like, it's just
so fantasy.
It makes me so sad.
Ice.
Is there anything in the... Oh, I see.
Recipe!
Oh, vanilla ice cream!
I can't see in there, so...
Put that back in.
Yeah, and put you back.
Oh, that's sugar.
We're gonna throw the other bag.
Now we can make all the ice cream recipes.
Yahoo!
Very fast.
Loves the fireflies.
Ribbit.
I want to see him walk more.
how rippeting ribbit firefly from honky star rail then that
guy would be a duck not a frog three varieties of dessert
all right does like does like two different types of ice
cream count or does he want like ice cream cookies and pie
you know Is he picky like that?
Hmm.
Maybe it's like three different kinds.
This one's easy.
Milk, ice, sugar, chocolate bar.
In the oven.
Wait, we're putting the...
We are putting the...
The ice cream in the oven.
Sugar, chocolate bar.
Oh wait, sugar here.
Oops.
Chocolate.
Checks out.
That looks good.
Jake!
How does he eat it?
Oh!
Oh no!
Cool.
Alright, that's one.
Let's then do...
cookies.
Sugar, chocolate, bar i like i just keep all the things open
now guys i can't be bothered to shut doors we're friends
with everybody we're friends even with the demon in our
pantry call me snow white flower and water i
guess once i run out of stuff i can just uh we haven't had
to fry much thing many things the oven does it for us but um
Once we run out of stuff, I can just shut the door and
refresh.
Selly, I want fried ice cream.
Oh, I want fried ice cream.
Wait, oh, I took a bite of that one.
If anybody gets fried ice cream, tell me.
I'll come possess you.
Please, I hope you don't want it because I want it instead.
I think that was extra stinky today, I could tell.
That's so rude.
I know I need to shower.
but like...
Come on!
Alright, let's do it.
Blueberry...
Pie.
Yeah, I'm gonna do blueberry pie because I'm lazy and I
don't want to slice some apples.
Blueberry!
Yes.
What else do I need?
Sugar butter.
What is it?
A water.
Water.
I wonder how many friends are in this game.
I think you go to the stir...
I think I've been stirring it the wrong way.
Do you like that umamusume gift, Minto?
Which one?
Which umamusume gift?
Sweat.
Oh, that looks so good.
Sweating Minto is cute, too.
I try to be clean.
Oh, the Bakushin one!
I have seen it.
Give me my key.
Oh don't...
Wait, can I have it please?
Oh thank you.
Where does this go to?
Not here.
Oh!
Coffee!
Why is the coffee a skull?
Steak and eggs.
Ah!
He's back!
You're back, you're back!
Pants!
Um, you didn't even knock this time, rude?
Okay.
Uh, what does he want?
I think it's in here.
I think whatever he wants is in here.
A bug.
Can I put water in this?
Oops.
Ah!
Sorry.
I guess we'll wait.
See if something comes.
Maybe I need to put the Bigfoot mug out.
What's this one?
Oh, it's you!
It's you!
It's you, pants!
You have your own mug!
It's you!
Aww!
I wish I could sit with you.
It would be so fun.
I'm just sitting together.
Gotta put this like in here.
Alright.
You want some toast?
Then he waddle these out.
Pants is my favorite.
Umah.
Me too.
I miss him already.
Oh, the cup and the coffee!
This guy looks, maybe he's Bigfoot.
He's got the big...
The mug, maybe he wants the Bigfoot mug.
My bad.
Sorry.
Sorry, Grandma.
Oh,
a cup of...
Oh, I want some coffee now.
A fresh one for ya!
Bacon!
Exit bacon!
Oh my god.
No?
No good?
Creamer?
Sugar?
I think we do have a big foot.
Oh!
Half life.
Whoa.
Okay, we'll just leave that right there for now.
All right.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, Jake.
Is it a chicken?
Very organized.
The chicken portrait is so majestic.
Gray wants.
three meals with beef.
Oh, I have to take a picture.
Come here, you.
Say cheese.
Sassfoot.
Ooh, that's a good one.
That's a really good one.
That might be my best picture yet.
Smells like beef.
Sassfoot wants four breakfast items.
Oof loves the smell of fresh coffee, but seems to hate the
taste.
Oh, I hope the wind doesn't blow him off the branches.
I remember that fish basket.
This gent is such a hopeless romantic.
He would always sing verses by the fire for a rose.
We have the rose.
You can feed Bigfoot.
This game is so veto-coded.
Few are graced by its presence.
A true honor to be part of its gaze.
It has been many years since I've been there.
Since I've seen this friend about the evening's
ever-watching eye.
You can watch their dances for hours, simply mesmerizing.
So there's 16 friends we have.
We're about almost halfway there.
All right, nice.
Okay, let's feed Gray.
He wants some beef, baby.
All right, well, we got a lot of stuff with beef in it,
though, so we got this.
Taking a nap before work.
Have a good stream.
Thank you!
Have a good nap.
Was that sassy from Dexter's lab?
All right, let's start at the beginning.
What do we have that we haven't made also?
Toast, pancakes, omelette.
Eggs and bacon.
Eggy sandal.
Steak and eggs.
Let's do that.
Potato slice.
Steak.
Wait, did it say fried steak?
Fried steak and fried egg.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, I didn't mean to do that.
I'm nervous to have a date tonight!
What if...
There we go.
What if it gets serious and she tells me I can't watch Minto
anymore?
Quinn, no, that would never happen.
Tell her to watch Minto too.
Easy.
Have fun on your date!
Wait!
What was this?
Burnt egg!
Aww!
I didn't know you could do that.
Yeah, convert her into Ibu.
Okay, I'm...
I'm scared.
Oh!
Easy, easy.
all right fried egg potato slice i think we have that
already potato slice
soon everyone in the world will be eyeballing yes rip and
tear until it is done wow that is this a breakfast steak and
eggs where's our dog there you go boy
It's not for you!
How do I feed you boy?
There you go.
It's a classic.
Good boy.
Well, we'll just make it again for Sassy.
All right, staking eggs.
Consult our guardian about finding a new steward soon.
I think I know just the person.
Is it me?
It's popular in the U.S.
at least.
Okay, let's do...
Ground beef should work, right?
And beef stew?
We could do this one.
I think I have another potato slice, actually.
Red.
Potato.
Uh...
Carrot.
Broth and steak.
Oh yeah, that was close.
Perfect.
The soundtrack in this game is like too good.
Making me a little emotional as we like cook for our
friends.
It's kind of so sweet, no?
We're cooking for our friends and we have this nice
soundtrack happening.
Oops.
Carol.
That was a beef stew.
And our fridge says node.
It's this game was made for me maybe.
Oh, that looks awesome.
Come here, boy.
Oh.
Hey, boy.
No.
I'll put it in front of your house.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
All right, one more beef thing for you.
Where's Sash?
I heard him.
What else do we want to make?
Let's do the meatball sub.
I think I have some bread slices in here somewhere.
Bread slice?
Perfect.
Tomato sauce and ground beef.
Organized chef.
Absolutely.
I know where everything is in my kitchen.
Where is the salt?
Salt.
Nice.
And tomato sauce.
Oh, that's an apple.
Spin.
Is this making you hungry, guys?
Do you think I could be a great chef?
I'm just gonna throw things in the oven exactly as this is
right now.
Art imitates life, therefore...
Whoa!
That looks juicy.
Therefore, if I throw all my things...
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Wait.
What is... What are you doing there?
I can pet the dog!
Don't run, please!
Let me pet the dog!
Hold on, let's open this.
Okay.
I can pet the dog!
Where'd he go?
Come here, stop running!
Oh my god, he's like a real dog.
Please, stop running!
I can pet the dog!
Oh, he's turning green.
Oh, he turns green.
Oh, my gosh.
That is a real greyhound behavior.
Makes you feel better.
I was only vaguely aware steak and eggs for breakfast was a
thing.
But Chikton, apparently there are tons of places around me
that serve it.
No way!
You could try it.
I feel like steak is heavy on the tummy, no?
Reassigning Minto to the mess hall team on Mother Base.
Where was I assigned before?
Entertainment?
Nobody tell her a slow cooker is just an oven you throw
things into and get a fully cooked meal out of.
You're right.
Wait, wait, so I can throw it in, jar and all?
Alright, we opened up this room.
The bathroom.
Read me, please.
Midnight greetings, my dear.
Watching misty fingers rise through trees, a strange thought
has taken haunt.
A flavor of drowsiness now dances alongside the light in my
soul.
The twilight whispers hold not a tinge of concern.
And so I shall trust their calm as I prepare to rest until
the new steward's arrival.
I think I was right, you guys.
Fish and chips!
A blue bead.
Oh.
Fish chowder.
Why is all the fish stuff in the bathroom?
Oh.
Green bead.
towels more towels chicken parm
that scared me i think that's the thunder oh country fried
chicken don't tell me there's a fish at the toilet seat
The blue bead goes into the blue bead hole and the green
bead goes into the green bead hole.
And we have no other holes to...
Hmm.
Oh.
Chicken noodle soup!
Is this gonna flood?
No.
All right.
Doesn't seem to be any friends in here, at least, though.
We gotta find the red bead.
Somewhere.
The music in there is kind of creepy.
All right.
Let's make some breakfast items, yeah?
Oh, very long.
Just once big dinner.
I wonder if I can bring him inside.
Not sure this is a dog.
All right.
I think we can bring him in.
Where's...
Here, here, here.
Come here, boy.
But do we want the thing that we're not sure is a dog or not
inside?
Um...
Alright, we'll get Sasfoot, and then we'll try whatever the
heck this guy is.
The fishy...
Fishing basket.
Should really feed him.
I did!
I gave him three whole meals!
Ha ha ha!
Big dog or short deer.
Wait, four breakfast items.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Hungry, hungry, hungry.
Does toast count?
Toast is a breakfast item, no?
I got him in!
Hey boy, hey boy.
Yeah.
He's in!
Time for steak.
Pancakes count for sure.
Pancakes have to count.
All my friends are just walking around.
It's in water.
Pancakes.
We need maple syrup.
Why does my flashlight do that?
Cats and dogs living together.
Mass hysteria.
Yeah, but a cat raised by a dog is like the funniest thing
ever.
Hey there, boy.
Hello!
Sass!
Oh, there you are.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Alright, pancakes.
Did you ever see the video of a cat raised by horses?
No!
How?
How does that even work?
A cat raised by horses.
Alright, pancakes.
Omelette.
We could do an omelette too.
Let's do that.
We have a cheese slice.
We have a mushroom slice.
I'm getting rid of my slices.
This is good.
Uh, carrot, potato...
Tomato slice?
Oh, nice, nice.
Now we just need to fry our egg.
Easiest ever.
I want to make new things, though.
I don't want to just...
I'm trying not to...
Oh, nice, okay.
Yippee!
If I get close, does anything happen?
I guess nothing happens.
Homelet.
Sayus.
Are you out here?
Where is my friend?
Where is Bigfoot?
By the coffee?
No.
I like that it's gone cold now.
It doesn't have like a...
Oh, there you are!
The search for Bigfoot is real.
Alright, that's Tool?
Alright.
Bacon!
We haven't made that one actually.
Let's fry some bacon.
Oh wait.
Oh no no not raw.
Oh no.
Hey.
Oh.
You don't like it.
That's a bad bacon.
It's bad bacon.
I'm sorry.
Okay, that was a vegan.
He's like, I know you didn't mean it.
I tried to give him bacon.
Any dog would want bacon.
Okay.
And...
Flip!
Yes!
Alright.
One bacon?
It is one bacon and one fried egg, yeah.
Breakfast staple coming up.
Yes, standards.
Do you ever think about how you cook bacon but bake cookies?
Minus two.
Oops.
I think he shows up every time he wants pets.
I'm really bad at cooking these aren't.
aren't I?
Oh, yay.
Oh, I can stand close now.
Bacon and eggs.
Eggs and bacon.
Where are you, sassy?
I made this just for you.
It's really delicious.
A pack of protein.
Don't just stand there, yo.
All right, one more.
Run.
Um.
Is grilled cheese breakfast?
Is mayonnaise a breakfast?
Uh.
Chicken par We don't have any chicken I haven't gotten any
fish either Maybe after we feed Saris
I feel like Grilled cheese sounds like a That's what dogs do
I feel like I feel like Grilled cheese sounds like a
breakfast Also thank you Brandon For this to be dead Thank
you
We did pay We did pancakes.
We did omelette.
We did eggs and bacon.
You know what?
Let's just try toast.
It's so simple.
And then we'll have lots of bread slices for anything that
we might need it for later.
A classic.
Simple toast.
I'll give him an end slice of it.
I hear him wandering.
Do we have one more lock in here, so...
I have to go.
Thanks for the stream showing your cooking skills.
As Italian, I'm really proud of you.
Thank you, Bobius!
Thank you.
Good night.
Did I say it right?
Oh, here you go.
Oh!
Ah, it worked!
Thank you.
Thank you, Bigfoot.
What's his booty look like?
Wow!
That's a sizable romp!
It does open up this one.
Chicken!
Oops.
Why wouldn't... Let me... Oh, there we go.
Balls?
What's it mean, boy?
What's it mean?
Oh, for soup!
Uh-oh.
Wait, what just happened in my game?
Uh, oh!
My mouse just died!
Wait, one second!
I was like, wait, I can't move!
I gotta plug up my mouse.
It did say it was not.
I thought it was gonna die sooner.
It told me last night it was dying.
It had been dying since before I started Bioshock.
He...
I've just been lazy about it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Plug in my mouse.
Does that work?
Seems like it.
All right.
This mouse lasts, you know, for as much as I am on my
computer and everything, this mouse lasts an incredibly long
time.
It's like, it's really awesome.
You know, I always get kind of nervous about wireless stuff
because Having to charge it is kind of a bit of a pain,
right?
But this thing lasts forever.
It's really awesome.
Okay, we just got bowls.
Let's see.
We did sash foot.
This one we don't have access to this room yet.
And pants.
And whatever is in all of these.
Like, yeah, there's this...
There's this lock too.
To the ghost.
Where'd you go?
And then also...
Will it come out of the toilet?
We need the red one, the red bead.
I'm assuming it's in here, right?
Nice bathroom.
Thank you.
Does anyone else think this dog suits mint well?
Why do you think that?
What's your reasoning, huh?
Can you open the cabinet?
Yes,
we can.
Oh, the chicken!
It's chicken burrito.
Fish.
Let's just close that.
Anything else under these towels?
Thank you to whoever told me to open this cabinet.
I was too much of a dummy to even realize.
Alright, so we got...
Wait, let's go put the fish in the fish basket and see what
happens.
Excuse me.
Oh, but I probably need my camera, right?
Oh, we'll go back for it.
Ah!
Oh, what are you doing up there?
What are you doing up there?
What?
There's an octopus in the tree!
Uh, camera.
Oh, there we go.
I feel like I've heard of this, like, legend though, an
octopus.
It's, like, not an umah, but it's like...
I think I remember making Valentine's cards based on this
guy.
The Pacific Northwest tree Octopus.
I think it used to be like a fake website.
I don't think it's appropriate to use the toilet on stream.
I'm so sorry.
I think it used to be a fake website that was based off of
this, this, this octopus, right?
Yeah, does someone else remember it?
Oh my god.
Say cheese.
Gerald.
Oh my gosh, Gerald!
What do you want?
You want some fishy fish stew?
Oh, let me check.
What you want first.
Gerald wants four meats of sky or sea.
Okay, so two chickens and two fish.
Okay, we can do that.
Fish and chips, coming right up.
Uh, bread?
Oh, potato slice one?
So much bread.
There's gotta be another potato slice in here.
No?
Cheese?
Cheese, carrot?
Okay, let's get...
So it's potato, slice three, and fried fish.
Is the fish going to be in here?
No.
We need some modern updates for those cryptid Valentine's
cards.
I'd buy those.
Maybe next year, right?
Maybe I can make them next year.
Fish.
Wow, that sounds such a cute looking fish.
It's like your stereotypical fish.
I didn't know I didn't realize they would be in such demand
Let me pet you
How is this game I've never even heard of it Is it scary?
I can't handle it?
No it's like a creepy But it's not there's no jump scares or
anything It's very cozy actually We're just cooking It's
just kind of spooky vibes but it's not like a Jump scare or
in your face kind of spooky.
Just creepy vibes.
Fish and chips.
For the octopus in the tree.
Yeah, see, you got like big foot walking around.
That's just a little goofy.
Oh.
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh, my god.
He's scared.
turn me.
Okay, maybe there are jump scares.
Alright.
He wanted two.
I wish I could run through bushes.
Oh my god, the dog.
Alright, that was one fish.
Let's do another fish.
Fish.
Fish chowder.
Potato slice.
Fried fish.
I think we have one more potato slice.
Nice.
Uh, milk.
Fried fish.
Fish chowda.
Hoi!
Nice.
And gravy.
Butter and flour.
Creepy, cozy, goofy, cute.
Are we talking about this game or meinto?
What are you talking about?
Wait, what was it?
Butter?
Flower?
I mean there is a demon in here.
I think this is the scariest part of the game.
My cord is going into my bowl.
Gravy.
I'll aboard the gravy train.
Put a whole milk box in the oven.
Nice.
That's how we do it here.
It's just...
The oven has the right idea.
The oven goes...
Yes, you wanted fish chowder.
Yes, yes.
You wanted fish chowder, I understand.
You safe.
Oh, great oven.
Make something with this.
Oops.
Mayoshi is the goofiest, comfiest, cutest creep around.
I don't think...
Wait, no, I'm creepy.
Scary.
spooky ghosty creep I'm a creep I'm a weird oh I think
there's something wrong with me time to make a chicky chicky
let's do we can do these two fried chicken let's do fried
chicken and potato slice.
We got one last potato slice.
And fried chicken.
Whoa!
Ooh!
Oh my gosh.
Flintstone's core.
Can I pet that dog, Minto?
You can pet the dog.
Hold on.
It kind of looks like a corn dog.
Okay.
Nice.
Where'd my dog go?
Come here, dog.
What's her name, Gray?
Ah, so cute.
What else do we need?
Gravy!
Wow, so many eggs.
I'd be all for smart appliances if they were like that oven.
I would like to make friends with it.
No, instead we have fridges that tell us that we have
tomatoes when it's really strawberries.
I'm a freak.
I'm an abu.
That looks good.
Some country fried chicken, y'all.
Ye-ha!
We're in the country.
There you go.
I shouldn't hide here.
Alright, one more chicken.
Tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki.
I wonder if eggs count.
pasta cheese slice we can do easy cheese slice pasta I think
then tomato and salt I believe bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep
bleep bleep bleep bleep the game is making me hungry me too
and I just eat
awesome burnt chicken always good night eh Mom, get the
camera, I'm on the thumbnail.
Raccoon!
Do you like a PB&J?
Who wants a raw chicken?
No!
Who wants a burnt chicken?
I love grandpa raccoon.
Who wants a raw chicken that I put in the fryer?
Okay, here we go, here we go.
In the middle, in the middle.
It's not my fault.
Not now, dog.
The game is giving me so much chicken.
Okay.
I ordered food from this place, but They keep telling me
they're ghost, but it keeps burning the food.
I'm giving it out a four out of five with hopes for
improvement.
You're so generous.
Yes, some of us are still being trained in the art of the
flip.
Some like it crispy.
That's honestly, this doesn't look so bad to me.
It doesn't even look dry.
Why do I have to fry it before I put it in the oven?
oven having accidentally eaten raw chicken before i would
advise against it raw chicken i think like raw beef seems
not doesn't seem so bad but raw chicken just seems like just
seems slimy and all
yippee it just doesn't seem appetizing what are your
thoughts on burnt marshmallow burnt the best.
Whoa, that looks so good.
Chicken parm.
I love me.
Oh, the burnt-er, the better.
Give me carcinogens of the fire.
So good.
Yeah, when it's all gooey on the inside, but so burnt on the
outside.
What do you have for me?
Thank you!
The moon key.
I think this is our second to last key that we know of right
now.
This opens the last room at least.
Oh no, we have two more keys.
The moon key.
Oh!
Like we have this one and then we have the...
Oh hi!
We have this one, which is...
Wait.
Oh, no, just kidding.
No, we do- oh, this is the bowl.
What do you want?
I forgot about that one.
Um, pants.
Something that was locked away.
Seems very wise.
Always in the same spot.
How did he get there?
It took me a while to figure out what this one wants, so I
keep his favorite snacks dashed away from the other
critters.
Yeah, let's try the slop.
No, he doesn't want to slop.
Maybe something comes out of it.
Right?
Is it always slop?
I've thrown...
I've thrown burnt chicken in there before.
Maybe it mutated.
Okay, why don't I give up?
Slop gotcha.
Let's try the black and white room.
Enter the oddities room.
Oh, I can't get in there.
There's an outside there too.
Heavy.
Fruit salad.
Yummy.
Gullab jamun?
What is that?
Typewriter handle.
Okay.
What is that?
Oops.
Um, wait.
I meant to put it on the couch.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh.
Ah.
Uh.
Chips and guacamole.
It's an Indian dessert.
Oh!
Did I soft-lock my- oh my god.
The typewriter was literally right here.
Avocado!
Um, there's a lost and found thing.
Let me see if it works.
No!
Stinking way!
Oh my god.
The game is kind.
Ghost Rider.
Once there was a wizard who came from old snake mouth.
Went clockwise round the mountain.
Landed one pace past due south.
Done shopping at Lambtown.
Trekked back the way he came.
Grown in hand the man ended.
north's flame.
At sunset with bag and sword, the wizard made for east.
His goal was the town named for beyond fields of evil
beasts.
There we go.
I know we got something here.
I think I need to hang stuff here maybe?
Hmm.
Does it have to do with this?
one past one pace past due south it's either this or the
clock right
have you tried meugenics the dialogue is super funny the
game's fun too you know whether I was gonna actually play
meugenics and then I was watching I watched like the trailer
and I was like I don't think I like how the cats are treated
in the game.
So, um, I decided against it.
Because I was interested, um, with, like, the creator and
everything.
But the game just seemed kind of not nice.
With the cat to the cats.
I'm not really good with that kind of stuff.
So, I forgot about this.
Shut up.
No.
No, no.
No, it's the butt.
The moon shines bright to greet my strange new friend.
As flames act for brethren, peddled beauties capture my
gaze.
Oh, uh, uh, uh, Uh, camera.
Camera.
He's so dreamy.
What a gentleman.
My bones.
Everybody, my bones.
He's gonna make me boneless.
No, no, no.
Ooh.
Please, stand still.
Why are his hands like that?
Sorry.
Oh, will this go in the book of pictures?
Aww, he's so cute!
Oh, so...
Once for vegetarian meals.
Oh, he's such a hopeless romantic.
Aww, I would always sing verses by the fire for a rose.
Can I get a large lamp?
Yeah, imagine if they were like, okay, um...
I'm watching the time.
this up fast i just realized oh no well if you have time to
finish before the concert we gotta go go go mushroom
stir-fry mushroom two
wasn't it pasta
okay no more no more messing around pasta butter mushroom
slice i gotta go get a mushroom
I heard this game was short, so I thought I would be able to
finish it in time.
Mushroom slice.
Oops.
We've just been having so much fun.
That's so cute.
How did he say it?
Four?
Four vegetarian meals?
Does grilled cheese count?
Can I jump this?
Oh, he can't jump at all.
It is such a joy to have this midnight snack.
A lovely meal you've given me, my friend.
Oh!
I love moth.
Alright.
We could do a mushroom soup.
Broth.
Um, potato slice.
I think we have potato slice?
No, we have only bread.
Toast!
Win in doubt!
You want four vegetarian meals?
I got the toast for you, buddy.
A toast!
To our moth friend.
Raise your glass.
When she was gone, I feared this art was lost.
A wondrous song of flavors ringing true.
Oh, when she was gone...
Oh no, I think she did die.
PVAJ!
Sorry, dog.
One second, I'll pet you in a second.
Peanut butter!
A classic.
And then it's...
Oh, sugar.
Oh, no.
I mix you and strawberry.
Peanut butter can contain rat hair.
Might not be vegetarian.
That's disgusting.
Don't say that.
Ew!
Oh.
It's swinging hard.
the anxious mind back and forth back and forth when she was
gone i feel oh the spirit this art was lost how did you know
she made that for me too this is so sad this is so sad
grilled cheese grilled cheese we're using all of my bread
slices It's perfect.
Chase!
I'll make it just like 100 different types of sandwich.
Can we date him?
Is this a dating sim?
Grilled cheese.
Have I made the grilled cheese before?
Maybe not.
Behold, my greatest love, a tasty snack.
He's so cute.
Your kindness shows in all you've done for us.
As wind rocks, the branches does flame cradle the soul.
Crest half.
Okay, so I need to figure out...
First of all, I need to figure out where this goes.
to figure out this puzzle so I could open this.
In the door.
Oh, you're right.
Thank you.
I don't think it's this one.
But, um...
Oh, I think it may be these symbols.
Okay, four.
Uh.
Jazz.
Four.
Null.
Ponder of time can touch voices once spoken through this
device.
Null.
I like the music in here.
Soul.
Dog.
The beads!
Bean burrito!
Who spilled the beans?
I like the music and hear a lot Wait, I want the OST to this
game so bad Guys, I think I need help with this one
Went clockwise round the mountain Landed one pace Past due
south Such a vast world Perhaps I shall one day discover So
Um One Another twilight Our my switch my strange friend I'm
confused okay I said clockwise right so seven do you think
it's the big hand or the little hand oh seven done shopping
at Lumbtown he trekked the way he came a couple paces past
North's Flayhan
What do you guys think this one is?
North's Flame.
Two?
There's like nothing for me to...
Ten?
Have you been graced by the giant of the stars?
I don't think so.
At sunset with Baggins, where there was a way made for the
east.
His goal was to be on fields of wildness.
or evil beasts.
As time creeps forward, remember this moment is a constant.
Good job, guys.
We did it.
Whoa!
Oh my god, it really is Outer Wilds.
At last, you have made it.
You have proven a worthy steward of our sacred home.
Outer Wiles!
We sense overflowing compassion as you stand in this grove.
The gathering of this chosen family awaits beyond the final
meal.
Remember to take care.
And make good memories.
This
one.
This one.
Did- did- did- did- did- I'm trying to open it?
I'm trying to open it.
That wasn't me how long!
Serial!
Find all the ingredients.
Fortunate gems recipe.
Are you here for your cereal?
Oh, maybe the gems.
Maybe he wants the gems.
What are you doing here?
Is this really an urn?
Oh, no.
Grandma is dead.
Did we get all the recipes?
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
Yeah.
3, 4, 5, 6.
Oh, no, we didn't.
We missed a couple.
Where's the gems?
I wasn't looking.
I was only...
I was only looking at the...
The numbers.
Missing 22.
Oh, fortunate gems!
Serial milk, a bowl, and a spoon!
That's why there was the...
I was wondering, because...
Wait, a fork?
Oh.
Oh, bowl.
Okay, bowl and spoon.
I was wondering why there were like a...
Oh, my bad.
Why there was cutlery in there.
Cereal?
And milk.
Yeah, cereal in the oven, baby.
Coming right up for you, little buddy.
Fortunate...
Oh my gosh, we got orange juice out of that somehow.
somewhere
Yeah He loved it I'm coming I'm following
What's happening?
It really is outer wilds!
Pants!
We'll keep it.
It's cute.
We got seeds.
What's this?
My dear, as I put ink to thods, memories of bygone summer
nights flow.
Cricket songs touched by the scent of charcoal and pine,
preserved over a lifetime.
The verses for all who reside in this space.
I feel like I should have saved this game for summer.
It's so sweet.
When these words are found, the little ones have made a new
friend and you a new family.
We will meet again.
May a lifetime of songs fill you.
Love XX.
Oh!
My friends!
Who the heck is you?
Wait, I think that's the demon.
All the different vibes are so cute!
Solid snake even showed up!
Goober!
Can I pet my dog?
Wow!
Everyone's here!
Solid chicken!
This is so sweet!
Join
the celebration!
Backyard Bonanza!
That was so cute!
Voice actors?
It does.
Should I have a voice actor?
That was so stinking cute.
Felt like a mini...
A mini, like, uh...
Outer Wild successor.
Wow!
I hop!
That was so cute.
The creatures!
Thank you for playing!
Yeah, spiritual successors somehow.
Yeah, I was just so cute.
Oh, all of our recipes and stuff are like our ingredients.
Wait, I want to resume the game right quick.
Oh, wait, this is so cute.
Cute little game that made me very hungry.
I'll grab some dinner while watching you on Nimi's stream.
Yeah!
We don't have so much time.
I just want to look at this real quick.
This one we didn't get.
The evening's ever-watching eye.
And this one maybe is the eye boo that shows up.
Let me see.
Friend!
Keep that.
Alright, let me let you win.
Once to find kindred spirits.
Oh sweet!
Oh my god!
I want to see if I can get like photos of these, you know?
Oops.
Where did I throw the camera at?
Wait.
Where did I throw my camera at?
I'll just do the lost and found.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh.
Giant deer thing.
Welcome back to our grove.
While our time is shared, may we find peace in meditation.
Zipperink, feel better!
Feel better.
This was so sweet.
Thank you.
This was so stinking sweet.
In a reality form, of questions my strange little friend's
kindness is not one so we have once to see the forest at
peace we are graced by its presence a true honor to be part
of its gaze this is the most accurate depiction i could come
up from memory it's pretty good actually i admit i was kind
of grumpy from work but my heart is fully melted i feel so
at ease resting glitch bears i'm glad i hope you again.
I'm sorry that work made you grumpy.
Thorego, thank you so much for the peek!
Did Mothman take your bones?
Are you okay?
Because you're a ghost.
Excited for the concert?
Me too!
I don't remember my mother's face.
I want to try and get these right before we go though.
The evening's ever watching eye.
So the moon?
And then this one is like a bush.
By offense, this guy...
No?
Oh my gosh, you're scared of me.
This one?
The fireflies?
Oh, maybe.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, firefly!
Now I think about it, this game was so... Courage the
Cowardly Dog.
Nice... It is!
That's a good way to describe it.
That is a good way.
And then the moon.
The moon!
Fill out the photo album.
You can watch their dances.
Oh, once nothing?
On a diet?
You don't see these guys around much anymore.
Like a lot of moisture.
Once nothing?
Can't eat?
Oh, it says moon here.
the bunny did I get all the achievements let me check oh I
did not oh I guess there's like who needs a cookbook anyway
I guess if you make a bad meal basic safety why would you do
that obtain 100 pieces of slop there's an achievement for
getting slop hold back the darkness of the night afraid of
the dark and master chief Make every...
Not chief, not chief, master chef!
Master chef, make every meal!
And then there's one hidden achievement.
I wonder what that could be.
Master chief!
You guys would make the same mistake, I feel.
The OST.
Devs, if you're watching, please.
Release the soundtrack.
It's too good.
I was clicking on this earlier.
How many more do I have?
Did I get it?
Wait, I'm at 30 out of 100 still.
Okay, I'll give up.
Cortana set over to bake.
This was such a cute game.
Our note is going to be...
Oh hey, it's different now.
I know what it says.
Oh.
It says.
Dreams.
Sweet dreams are made of these.
I have to disagree.
We're nerds!
Wait, no way.
There's no way that we would get node and then nerd.
Did you just say nerds?
Nerdies?
100% Aminto game.
I feel so.
This was so cute.
so satisfied.
Right pants.
Yeah, waiting for your cereal.
I hope you guys enjoyed the game as much as I did.
And in 20 minutes starts Nimi Nightmares 3D Concert!
I will be a guest as well as Phoebe.
And she has some other special guests as well.
So, yeah.
It was so fun.
Let me pet you.
There we go.
Hot dog indeed!
Thank you, Troy Pratois!
Thank you guys so, so, so, so much.
I will see you when I see you next!
Thank you so much for the stream!
This was so cozy and cute and awesome!
I'm really glad we could...
I'm really glad we could play it, so...
The raccoon's on the rocking chair again.
Oh, I must have just missed him.
What's wrong with me?
I wish I could sit in the rocking chair.
You guys see that, right?
What was that?
Whoa!
Cool.
Cool, he was on the top of the fridge!
Osamito, everybody!
I'll see you in the concert!